I know there was that a complex list
that I don't know how you guys didn't
make it I have some ideas but it's fine
but like I don't really like look into
that [__] too much you know I I honestly
like never expect to make that kind of
[__] so like when I saw you guys shout
me out it meant a lot it was cool man
lists aren't important in the scope of
things but they're great to talk about I
love a list I'm never above arguing
about a list or just talking about [__]
whether we're on or not but I felt you
definitely should have been on it for
hip-hop media and you guys should have
definitely been on it I mean can we even
have the conversation of what what is
hip-hop media now to me you do hip-hop
media I'm not even quite sure if Maul
and I do hip-hop media I'm not sure if
the podcast space
is very much hip-hop media per se I
think you guys do comments touches
there's touches of it at this point
right but podcasting has had to expand
so much it's tough to like just do the
Hip Hops that's become Niche how crazy
is that biggest genre in the world the
podcasting has gotten so big you can't
just do yeah I think that's why your
guys's [__] is so dope could you guys
talk about just everything like
whatever's going on like you guys have a
take on it for the most part you know
yeah and uh it's good
how's everything uh with this album man
yeah I used you had sent me well you
just sent me the album like 20 before
you showed up sorry yeah all the way in
I swore I sent it to you before and
another way here A bunch of songs before
yeah
um that that are on the album obviously
but I haven't listened to it front to
back but I know this has been like your
baby for a long time yeah it's been a
long time coming to me when I started it
was maybe like three years ago and
luckily I had a lot of great excuses for
why it was taking so long right one was
the pandemic obviously and especially a
great excuse I loved it can't can't do
anything right
um also even like with the other pod
breakup like I had to reset on a lot of
stuff so even getting Mull and I show up
and running and and you know starting
from zero with a whole new show was a
task in itself where the album kind of
took a bit of a back seat so you know it
was three years but I'm I can't say I
worked on it for three years like I had
to stop for a while which was good
though because I mean there's records
how do I put this album out
two and a half years ago right I
probably would have [__] hated it and
I think I would have regret it so like
shout out to China for kovid and shout
out to the old show for breaking up like
shout out to the China virus yeah it
really I'm sorry for everyone that lost
grandparents but it really helped with
my album I lost my grandma Yeah more
money than I ever had in the pandemic so
you know I can tell by the the plaques
well these plaques are just [__]
these are [__] you know that they
send people who play songs
you know broke my heart when I went into
certain producers Studios and saw all
the plaques but then realized they were
also DJs right and the labels used to
just send out plaques like you worked on
the miseducation of Lauryn Hill and like
no no yeah like I got a lot of my OG
homies who have like a big L uh
a big picture plaque from Maracas yeah
and then like I started to realize like
damn everybody who's an old head in the
music industry I know has one of these
like not everybody could have worked on
this [__] like and what did you work on
on the big picture like if you live in
L.A
what happened like you know but you know
one production credit that I see here
yeah so like the DJ plaques thing is
very like uh you know whatever I mean
I'm not gonna [__] turn them away
they look nice of course I'm jealous I
have no plaques I feel like I should
have some but I just never like went to
collect none of the emotional orange or
stuff has gone gold yet yeah we're like
quadruple platinum in Korea so you got
to get one of them yeah I have to get a
Korean plaque for sure yeah well listen
for people who don't know uh because I
feel like a lot of people know you yeah
um but they might not necessarily know
your story
um kind of give me a breakdown on like
how you got even involved because I I
think I first met you at like a Henny
palooza in La like maybe four or five
years ago six years ago was downtown
um but give me a breakdown on just kind
of how you got into the industry
obviously we know about the Joe Budden
podcast yeah
um well I mean it started well before
that yeah so um my barber in college by
Barbara I mean the only guy that had
Clippers on the floor in the dorm uh
shout out to my man Owen uh who I'm
still really cool with he was interning
at Def Jam and I didn't even know that
was like a thing right I was like you
can you can do that because there was
like internship programs at our college
but again I was like a freshman so I
didn't know much about that but I assume
like internship was like you interned at
the [__] financial aid office like I
didn't know there was real internships
per se
um he was like yeah I'll link you with
the person I'm interning for because I
guess like legally you could only do one
semester right Def Jam at the time right
so I interviewed with Shireen Taylor who
uh was at RCA forever she's been in the
business forever too
um with her she was the assistant to
Gabby peluso ended up getting the
internship and kind of just going crazy
in that building like I was
almost teetering on the line of annoying
but like I was right on that consistent
line where people [__] with me but I
was in every single Department talking
to every single person
um ended up linking with shot money and
just are even with the neighborhood
connection at that time he took me under
his wing and then where Shaw went I went
so I would say Gabby peluso Serene and
shot money were like the three people
that really introduced me into the music
business that's actually how I met
better Ben was working with Sean money
Benner's now my manager and this was
when I was 19 I'm 33 now so did you meet
Benner at one of those random beat
conventions in Phoenix
yes I used to do um what were those the
producer conferences what were those
called [__] I don't know I never could
go because at the time I was doing radio
in like Middle America but yeah I would
always see my friends I'd be like God
damn this is it was the producer
conferencing shout out to Sean because
ahead of his time he had every producer
you could think of all within like a a
Convention Center and they would have
Beats battles they would have like
conferences is for producers they would
have like Tech [__] like shot is such an
adult thing with that you were at those
no I was in high school
um how I actually met better my manager
and that's you know the podcast knows
him as well now was better in shop money
we're doing this thing called Def Jam
Cipher sessions Shaw was VP of a r at
Def Jam Better was moving around the
industry and they started this thing
that was like the main act at Def Jam at
the time for their region so for example
the first one was with Big Sean and then
a bunch of opening acts and then an
actual Cipher at sobs then they did the
South one that had big crit Cy then the
LA one the lineup was [__] nuts I
think it was was it Kendrick Dom Jesus
was nipsy on that too
YG and this was 2000 2010 Jesus
yeah two different booty days 2010 2011
yeah
um so they just did different regions
and we did them all at sobs
um I mean I've talked to Big Sean later
in life and he was like yo that Def Jam
Cipher session [__] was like kind of the
thing that made the building pay
attention to me I wasn't just the what
you doing [__] and right kid at that
time like they're like hey maybe we
should give him Marvin Gaye and
Chardonnay right
um so it was really cool to be on the
ground floor with that stuff and by the
way what happened to Roscoe Dash anyway
continue hey